I plan on doing more actually I'm doing
a movie coming up in a couple weeks
called spinning gold where I play
Giorgio Moroder who was the father of
disco and I have to do it talk about
putting yourself in a situation that you
don't normally find yourself in if some
disco know that I could do
[Music]
so I came here right no yeah I just I
just got it yeah it yeah yeah now so
yeah you win this round hey I noticed
and this is probably the Italian and me
uh-huh
I don't like that you got your name
outside on the wall yeah I think it
should be nondescript yeah don't yeah
kind of some some psychotic come by and
then oh this is where your podcasts out
of you know kind of like a little under
the radar no that's a good idea actually
I think also because there's a lot of
mental health in this building so it's
like yeah I think they're all gonna okay
you know one of those frakkin brain
hamster's relapses and next thing you
know they come nibbling through the door
[Laughter]
yeah but yeah that's the attack you guys
do hide-and-go-seek like every day 24
hours right no no one never knows where
we're at you know you gotta find out
that as well be Aniyah
so yeah but this is a nice spot you got
here and I like the mural and we were
talking about this before that I know
I'm not a big I'm not in the podcast
mafia but I do have a podcast yeah it'd
been been with Cory alia for five years
it's it's really popular popular enough
not to make the wall so you do you
sometimes does it feel like that
podcasting is like what does podcasting
feel like to you it must does it feel a
little psych goofy kind of or something
because you're me you're really like an
entertainer
so is this podcasting feel like a little
bit you know like ass not really my bag
sometimes or do you have any thoughts
like that on it well you know I like it
and I like doing podcasts not not as
often as maybe a lot of you guys I know
it's like there's a lot of you guys are
in your you know
the Schwab's the the Callens the cry
shores the Segura's and Rogin it's like
well you know it's like a little family
you guys got which is cool and you guys
go on each other's podcasts and yeah and
what have you but my podcast is not
really guest driven it's just two guys
kind of talking about their personal
private lives which is that a no-no in
the fact that it reminded me that's yes
I think I got a listen to Webster's what
they called it's called the Pete and
Sebastien show and that we get on for an
hour a week and it started about five
and a half six years ago Pete lived here
in Los Angeles and then subsequently
moved out to Fredonia New York and we do
the podcast through Sirius XM and it's a
it's only an audio podcast it's not a
video and and we have fun with it but
you know guys like yourself have really
really had an abundant of success doing
the podcasting and and it's great it's a
great way you know for you know what us
underling you know Steven my team
stevemartina no no no it has been its
unique it's almost like a fan it is
almost like a little bit of a family and
it's it's been dude this shit's blowing
my mind I didn't know podcasting was
gonna I remember cuz I did a podcast for
a couple years for like a year called
allegedly and it didn't do anything two
years we had like a celebrity guess and
III didn't really like it so what what
what was your tipping point where did
you take off on this well I went on
Rogen's one time and now was a psych man
people just want to hear people talk
about stuff and it kind of gave me just
a different perception of what podcast
him was and so then yeah then I just
started in my kitchen and was just kind
of like yeah I'm just gonna talk about
stuff that's going on you know and
sometimes a struggle sometimes it's not
I can imagine yours probably has more
recipes in it up it see there's a recipe
too
there's a lot of recipes actually
but yeah it's we have fun with it it's
it's it's a really really good podcast
it's just I wish it would reach a
broader audience we don't really put a
lot of time and energy into it because
you know it's just he's there I'm here
right so you got a big life going on now
yeah I mean I have a family and whatnot
not that is an excuse not to have a
podcast but I hope my father when they
leave me Father imagine how sad the
story's gonna be fire was never home he
was always an Encino record you never
took me to ballet class cuz he was in
podcast ville it is it is no but you do
a good job man I mean you should really
be proud of yourself and look at look at
where you know it's taken you you you
know you've you've gotten a huge
audience now on the road and not and
here now and and you're getting all
these movie parts and whatnot so you're
uh this is you fit right in here
he'd been fun yeah it has been fun man
it's been you know it's funny like Joey
Diaz called me this morning what's good
you know and you guys look up to him I
know and so he called me this morning
like what's good [ __ ] you know so
yeah you talked to a lot of like like
comedians off off the pot calls like
once a week
oh yeah yeah he's just like that and
he's always got you know for him
everything is three things it's a UH
its destination a sandwich and something
to read every time he tells you
information he's like dude here's what
you do
you're in Buffalo you go two blocks down
there you're gonna smell a guy right
don't look at him all right to the left
you're gonna see a sandwich shop looks
like it's out of business you [ __ ] go
in there right you order you order a
Reuben ask for four extra inches of meat
crack open a copy of Catcher in the Rye
and you're [ __ ] tremendous son every
time no matter where you are it's like
all you're in Tampa going to you can't
[ __ ] see anything right turn around
three times there's gonna be a lady
there with a [ __ ] uh you know a
couple of loose veal you know you grab
one of those [ __ ] man you know you
open a copy of Time magazine
from 1979 nobody can [ __ ] with joy he
always has like boom boom civics yeah
very specific no matter where you are
but he komete he just did a Sopranos
movie yeah that's what he was telling me
at the comedy star talked to him a
couple weeks ago he said he just got off
the Sopranos thing so and and you have a
new you have a movie yeah movie coming
out called the Irishman with De Niro
Pacino and Pesci the gangsters let's
Olin say their names again Roman let's
say let's say them like we like us
underlings
so who DeNiro Larry De Niro Larry de
niro Pete Pesci and Frank Scorsese man
so yeah it's coming out we don't know
when but sometimes this year but the
trailer dropped a couple weeks ago and I
I was really excited about it was it was
the first time I really saw any footage
from them from the movie and I got goose
bumps it was it was it's going to be
pretty special damn
so I played crazy Joe Gallo and I'm
actually in the trailer falling out of
the window so it's it's it's exciting
we're looking for AZ man and I saw the
green book that you did yeah green book
won the Oscar this year and yeah very
fortunate to land some of these roles
that you know I like dream roles for you
know like a lot of actors work 25 years
to get in movies like this and the
comedy has allowed me to you know open
the doors for other opportunity and then
the green book was one of those were you
know I'm working the first day with
Viggo Mortensen and you know he slapped
me in the scene and then after they
yelled cut yeah a nice little slap and
he goes it said okay okay do that no my
guy you wanted to lay me out lay me out
I'm up for anything so yeah it was it
was exciting so there's exciting things
going on I got a little baby boy that we
just had eight weeks ago so building the
family and
is it hard to concept is it hard to like
does it almost feel like hard to be
present sometimes me it's a lot going on
your life yeah there's a lot there's a
lot of thinking there's a lot of you
know sometimes I'm not in whatever I'm
in I might be thinking about other
things which I like to be present and
available but sometimes your plate is
really full and you just hard not to
think about what's going on I worry a
lot a lot of fear in in taking some of
the projects I take just really cuz uh
yeah well I'm doing this VMAs in two
weeks right I'm home oh yeah I heard
about that and honestly my first thought
was like what the [ __ ] is that crazy
well it's it's it's a challenge for me
because a it's not my audience I mean
see excuse younger yeah my audience is
typically you know thirty to sixty
jag-offs ambra jag also cufflinks I know
it's getting hot bro I'm joking man you
have a huge huge audience that gets good
entertainment so that's who you have
yeah so you're worried that well I mean
it's its first of all I mean you you all
know as a comedian when you do comedy at
a musical event yeah that you know
sometimes it could be difficult to
connect with the crowd just because you
know they're listening to music and then
you come on and you have to kind of
segue and do a joke here there so it's
not listing it right yeah it's some
hosting us i'm now you never saw the you
never would have thought that you'd be
hosting the vm and knows it wasn't on my
vision board right sit down
I do have a vision board actually and I
want a black son when they have two
black kids in my vision board yeah yeah
two black kids yeah okay so people
always I don't tell people that often
because they don't see it the way I see
it you know how do you see it I see it
as these don't want to be my son these
gonna be my sons one day I think other
people see like Oh a guy from the
southeast a couple of black guys on a
vision board you know I think they kind
of get uh you know they're looking at it
different so if I go into your house and
looked at the vision board you got two
two black kids up there yeah look
they're happy
the school book under his arm isn't my
son's man okay and no matter who my sons
are what you know what cause you know
what tent they come in they're gonna be
you know hopefully they're gonna be
reading decently and doing good stuff
you know but dude that's crazy you gonna
be hosting the VMAs you have to be a
little nervous huh I'm a lot nervous I
wouldn't be living if I'm not really
feeling this stuff so you know
music skewing younger never hosted
anything before you know like you know
you got to write the company for the
night you know and my comedy generally
is tested at The Comedy Store and
whatnot so the monologue that I'm
opening up with you know I've been
working on but haven't really tested it
in front of a live audience which I will
you know moving forward this week and
next but yeah it's it's it's a daunting
task but are you gonna talk about
celebrities and stuff you have to kind
of I mean MTV's turn if this was rob
dyrdek 24 hours a day I think I feel
like it's just that show ridiculousness
yeah there's a lot of that but I'm not
my Styles not ripping people to shreds
my style is a little bit more I'm gonna
tailor the comedy to what I what I do on
stage and kind of fit it into the
environment rather than go on stage you
go well Drake's here tonight yeah I
don't know it's not really what I do
what I do so right oh wow that's cool
though cuz that that's I think when I
heard about it I was like oh man it's
abassin gonna do that it's just
different it's just different than him
that would just to me it would seem so
scary you know it's frightening but it's
good it's a good frightening you know
like I believe that if you don't
challenge yourself in this business and
we've talked offline about this like you
know getting a little maybe your
momentum is not there or your passion is
not there maybe in certain different
things I feel that you know the
challenge is where you kind of get the
passion back and or putting yourself in
situations that you typically wouldn't
put yourself in to you know overcome and
succeed so you know doing that yeah
doing one this is definitely one of
those that's wild
so yeah it's been good though we were
you know where did how like I am the
outfits are next next next week I'm not
gonna come out there and see through
leopard nipples shirt how many gross of
sequins are in the mail right now there
might be a sequin a jacket or two
looking like a 60 year old Italian stop
he's trying to [ __ ] get one last run
at some [ __ ] over though no I want over
heel I want you to come out this in row
there's gonna be a lot of yeah I think
I'm the prop maybe one of the oldest
hosts I've ever had at least the may be
the only host I've ever had would gray
hair definitely so you might wanna know
who's being honest about their age as
well 46 years old doing doing the UH the
VMAs so yeah that's that's gonna be
exciting
hambo it's so crazy man it's crazy is it
is it strange to feel sometimes that
that's your life like isn't it sometimes
even with me just like in the past year
just getting things getting busier and
people coming out it's like it's crazy
how quick you adapt to it kind of and
then sometimes I don't feel embarrassed
that it's my life or something I mean
I'm grateful but I just feel it's almost
like my life the reality of some of my
life sometimes makes me a little bit
nervous if that makes any sense what are
you nervous about just like um I guess
just like there's a few feels like
there's a bigger expectation then you're
able to fulfill just as like a human
person you know it's almost like you get
bigger than you are as a person in some
are worried about fear of some of that
or something I don't know if that makes
any sense or not you know I mean I guess
in a way I mean for myself yeah I just
you know I just like to live a normal
life I I don't like to like feel like I
have to be doing something else and put
it this way the gym I work out I don't
have an office right I just have
a home and I work out of the home right
but it's getting a little crazy now at
the house a few children kids it's hard
to work it's hard to do anything so what
I've been doing is going to my gym and
after I work out a set up shop at the
gym at the gym now of Jesus which is
guys which I've done I've gone to
Starbucks I've got you know I've done
all that stuff you know
that's right throughout my whole career
I've always kind of like just set up
shop and and did things so how do you
bring in a laptop or you bring a printer
okay I just just you know catch up on
some emails on a table outside the gym
right like it'd just be my break up
monitoring the same guy that's editing a
full movie at Apple store you see those
guys you walk in this guys doing like
he's on final cut and when a doing his
uh short film yeah he's like well
everybody quiet down I need some room
tone I'm gonna get some air pods man
that's so sometimes you'll just do it at
the gym huh yeah you know I mean like
talking about just kind of living a life
that's kind of just normal and don't
have to feel like you have to adjust
your everyday kind of routine because
you've hit some type of success I know
I've always just trying to you know
let's just do because I feel like if you
stop doing the things that you normally
would do you lose the kind of like the
pulse of what people are doing what the
you know I like going to the stores and
the whole you know grocery shot like I
love all that's right and I'll continue
to do it just because I I enjoy it plus
I get a lot of like material from just
kind of living life oh yeah man I think
it will yeah when you say that I think
yeah I think yeah maybe my fear is like
it's not it's just like this / it's a
it's a on
perceptions like yeah maybe I feel like
I have to be different or something when
I was just you know don't maybe this
like this weird like pressure or
something I don't know but yeah I think
doing regular stuff like I like
someone's taking a bird scooter to the
gym in the morning you know and I don't
have nice calves and I have shorts on so
for me it's really humbling you know
taking [ __ ] lean calves out for a
spin on a birthday
39 years old but have you have you felt
at all safe anything I did it once or
twice and it just the you know the one
bump and it's over right yeah there's
not a lot of there's not a lot of
opportunity for safety I don't feel like
on them you know overall do one lady hit
the dirt bro everybody sprouts over by
me right it's like way to be on one bag
of groceries just hit the dirt on just
didn't move at all right instead of
helping there was like two people
yelling this [ __ ] down yeah and I at
least halt my horn real loud as I
[ __ ] drove off you know but she but
she did it man
groceries all over like yeah it's a lot
of well listen these birds you know it's
it's it's good for you want to go to the
gym you want to go to a buddy's house
finally pick one up you go but what I've
seen on these birds is like you were
saying people are carrying groceries
then I saw a guy that apparently the you
take a burden you you go and charge it
right and people make money the guy was
on a bird with tumors and his shoulder
okay it's just it's not made for that
you know I'm saying that's a locking bra
that's crazy
when you flock it man that's what the
bird yeah somebody you'll see some guy
at night just throwing them all into a
[ __ ] buffet and yeah and this is one
of your moves bro stole them from your
ass you got a noose on man that's
awesome huh yeah so got a little baby
boy
and yes and then just it's been a great
got two and a half year old daughter and
a lot a lot of stuff going on at the
house and I try when I'm home to spend
as much time as I can with my kids
whether it's taking my daughter to the
ballet or whatnot again just kind of
living live in the dad life and and
extracting material from from those
moments as well so yeah it's been really
really uh it's really it's a lot of a
lot of work but it's very rewarding
bringing up kids and having a son doing
it I know in your kind of bloodline it's
a big thing right oh yeah being a
full-time family it's nice to have a son
carry on the name the new old with three
daughters people like the name yeah so
yeah we have my father my mother were
extremely excited when a little baby
baby boy came so yeah I think we're
gonna I think we're we're done two is
good enough y'all gettin a tube hot
anything and what do you guys do do no
no man we can somebody sneak up on a to
go to [ __ ] shine yeah we we shank it
we shank it too yeah I don't know I
don't know what I'm gonna do yet we
haven't really discussed it has been
discussed but I don't have no idea what
yeah it's the least of my worries right
now right so we haven't even talked
about the shirt I think you know wore
the shirt just it's a beautiful piece
it's a beautiful garment well I remember
you said that yeah if you ever had a
different job it would be like a
concierge Adam so I could just see you
like I'll tell you this if you show up
in people's dreams or anything this is
what you this is what they're worth that
is a beautiful Maitre D' out hi yes top
knots dude go to prom funeral all of it
that's one thing is nice about Italians
like if they really they dress up it you
almost dressed for anything it could be
something severe could be a good you
know it could be a get-together it could
be a funeral it could be indictment you
know all the above yeah lady dress right
there well dressed well I won best
dressed in high school you really yeah
senior year took
I actually got there was a tie between
me and another guy I should I should
have took it home though but was
actually upset that I had to share the
award with the guy but yeah always
always a very particular about how we
look and I think it's stemmed from you
know the upbringing I would come down to
go out my mother's like where you going
with that I'm gonna go we're gonna go to
Dennis you know put thing you know go
put some nice slacks on and like do mom
we're going to Arby's MA yeah we got
good now we're gonna beat up that
Marilyn Pizza was sit down there sign
that sit down anymore no some of them
you go in there's just some Muppet just
gives you a scoop of [ __ ] pepperoni
brah if somebody pulls a gun in the
distance bro that place is going down
yeah like that you can't sit down and
eat there again bro Pizza Hut used to be
like a restaurant right dude it was so
nice yeah have you been at Pizza
recently yeah I picked up from I don't
think you can sit there's like a bench
we can wait but if you sit there and eat
it's gonna be hella awkward hooker but
it's yet merged with baskin-robbins and
it's just pizza used to be it was we
were going out we went to be tough yeah
those like kind of curly yeah been she
sat down and you had a pizza wow I
haven't been there in a while they had
they had yeah the crust was it was a big
pot at a couple video games usually in
the place yeah our family would go sit
in there I enjoyed that a salad bar
salad bar that's right they didn't have
a salad bar pudding on it I never
understood it but just five days ago
they shot you shut down 500 more dine-in
pizza locations it's going away that's
it
Pizza Hut's done weird eat your pizza
out here there's a nice place called
pizanno out here if you're looking for a
nice piece of pizza is there yeah
where's that at sound Robertson and
Melrose they just opened up location
Alton so also in Brentwood I have no
money and no stake in this place but
okay if you want some nice neighborhoods
bro I'm eating pizza more out here in
regional you know I'm eating pizza more
are you I don't know I want to tell the
listeners or the viewers where we're at
right but yeah
Pete's around here okay this is your
hood like a really close to Ricky get
gas you know what I'm saying
you can smell one from the other face
yeah that just bleeds in the gas bleeds
into the cheese who are you uh who's
somebody that you are kind of low-key
excited about seeing at the VMAs like
just to see do you already know
everybody's gonna be there and stuff yes
they've given me a list who am I excited
to see this is this is why they picked
me to do this is I don't really know a
lot about music and this is kind of what
they liked about it that I don't really
have a button on what's going on with me
with the music industry although I do I
know the Khaled's and and and from afar
and her and Halsey and all these yeah
all these artists I know but I don't
know like the ins and outs of like who's
throwing shade right yeah whatever that
means I don't we're on phone that I
ain't got a new owning on their camper
but Missy Elliott who I grew up kind of
listening to she's gonna know similar
body type to a village yeah I feel I
feel like we're similar in shape so
she's gonna be there she's gonna be
there and yeah there's a couple surprise
guests that I can't really mention that
I'm looking forward to meeting so crazy
man what a wild night that's gonna be my
mom just told me she's coming my
father's coming my in-laws are coming
I obviously my wife my whole family is
come with my kids I wanna bring my kids
there and get some photos with them all
yeah people at the Prudential Center
where they're gonna have it so yeah just
elaborate even on a production and of it
just looking at this cuz you know I know
a lot about production and putting on a
show what they what they have going into
this as far as the technology is just
sick it's amazing
and this some is in New York right this
is New Jersey Prudential Center in New
Jersey oh is that where they usually
either they usually have it last year I
think it was at Radio City they've had
at Radio City they've had it here and
that's a staple center they've
at Madison Square Garden Microsoft
Theatre at the Forum Barclays because I
went to one cuz I would did MTV show
when I was young right and so we went
what was that 20 years ago the VMAs yep
20 years ago so you went to the VMAs
went to the VMAs you got a ticket
somehow I don't even know right I get
out at the place I didn't know was gonna
be like I mean I'd seen it on television
but I get out get dropped off there Bono
is walking on the red carpet the same
time I am I think everybody's like
excited for me right dude and because I
have no clue Bono is no clue I've never
really listened to music I listen to
like um you know Allison change you know
I'd recognize them or Guns and Roses
maybe but um so people are going nuts
dude I have no idea go into the place
sitting I sat behind Chris Farley's
Brothers he had just died and I sat
behind his brothers sat next to Susan
Sarandon and Tim Robbins Wow
and NSYNC performed at some point in the
evening bro is long I'm Marie urinating
in the bathroom between Kid Rock and
Montel Williams Wow
you know that's a good person I can
bring those guys together you know and I
won't put an even I fell asleep in my
seat proptosis well I guess it was like
a long night and I just got kind of
tired and I just remember falling asleep
but had you know you were gonna be
wanted to get in the comedy back then no
I don't think so I think I does didn't
want to grow up like one thing about
comedy for me I just didn't you know I
didn't want to grow up I was like you
got to travel you didn't really know if
your girlfriend was your girlfriend you
know she didn't know kind of if he was
the boy you know yeah and yeah just for
the kid enough to grow up like he could
always get over whatever was going on
you could always go escape it for a few
days by going to do shows but the road
rules took you out of Louisiana yeah
yeah it took me yeah it was good because
I got to meet like I just got to see
something differently we went to South
Africa on it I remember no and I
remember being like holy [ __ ] you know
all these people are alive you know like
I just never really put it together
there was people like I'd seen a globe
but I've never put together like oh
there's really people over here like
being alive you know then you get there
and I'm like holy [ __ ] man
you know all these people gonna be in
heaven like this is crazy because when I
thought I haven't I thought kind of you
know kind of let a little bit of a
limited group you know but uh but then
you get over here and you're like damn
everybody's gonna be it's a whole world
often yeah I started giving me this idea
gave me this a different perception uh
globe came alive yeah hey khlo really
yeah I got four-dimensional so a little
bit more about the movie they don't want
to know so is it interesting like as you
start to build you kind of become a name
you know and so then it's like if you're
working with guys like that like do you
is it harder to like not be like dude
like would you not want to seem like
you're just like a regular guy with them
like do you have to try and pay like a
little bit of homage like do you feel
like any of that kind of thing on set or
what is it like kind of when I went on
set I told myself I'm not going to speak
unless spoken to
I didn't want to be that guy yeah and
I'm not that guy [ __ ] guy well you
don't go what are you gonna do go up to
Robert De Niro and go wow I really loved
you in casino right the first day I had
a scene with Robert De Niro and Joe
Pesci
and I didn't know I didn't sleep for a
couple of days before that I was really
kind of pining like a [ __ ] camping
his [ __ ] got crazy like how do you not
get any breasts man well I mean I was
just because I think I'm like like
neurotic you know like if I got
something to do like this VMAs two days
before that I'm gonna be up and down oh
and there's no sleep oh and they call
you out to the stage that's gonna be
[ __ ] it's live it's live man so with
this it was it was nerve-wracking
because I just I'm not an experienced
actor I don't have a lot of experience
on movie sets now and now to be thrust
into a movie where you're working with
you know
not only Martin Scorsese but probably
two of the actors that are maybe our
best of our generation and then you know
they're yelling action I'm just hoping
words come out of my mouth you know so I
was I was nervous going into that whole
experience but it's just like anything
else you know you do it and then you're
like okay you know cuz I there's there's
doubt there was doubt for me like do I
belong here right that's what I'm I
think I'm trying to get out a little bit
yeah that's what I would feel like to I
belong here am i pretending that I
belong here do they know that I don't
know if I belong here I don't give me
the things to be running through my head
but they leave me like ah this [ __ ] I
don't belong here or are they just
looking at me like a regular person and
all the doubt is just inside of me you
know that's what it is that you're
you're you it's all inside the questions
you have no one else is thinking that
you have to you have to think that but
you know that's what I was thinking I
was like am I gonna get on set and then
I was gonna go this is so we hired so
yeah there is a bit of self-doubt and
there's a bit of you know a lot of
anxiety and nerves at least for me and
then once we're up and running it was it
was off to the races so I didn't really
look back after that but I did have some
experience with the green book going
into this movie which I think that's why
I think a lot of things happen for a
reason you know like you get certain
things because they prepare you for
what's to come
right a plane you can't even see kind of
yeah with green book yeah where did you
guys shoot those scenes in order were
they out of order Green Book was in
order because you don't honestly know if
this is obviously me judging you but um
from the beginning like the first thing
when I see like helping with the luggage
I think or something there was some
scene I think are helping somebody had
just arrived somewhere yeah car I think
and by the end I could personally see
like wow he's he's so much more
comfortable but at the Christmas party
okay cuz that the first day was that the
luggage day well I didn't then talk
about nerves how I'd be so nervous I was
nervous for it I was nervous for you
watch 100% like that's so scary but no
joke do by the end I was like
sebastian just i mean knowing enough
about you didn't knowing a little bit of
like your mannerisms and how you look
even off of stage and stuff like like oh
man he seemed a little bit nervous but
by the end I was like damn he's dialed
in yeah no you're right you're very
perceptive the first scene for me was
nerve-wracking because it was like oh my
that was really my first big scene in a
movie with a big big actor and it's like
you got to rise to those occasions
because you know if you don't then
they're like right but yeah it was um I
hope I hope looking back at what I did
in the irishman when I watch it I could
because it's different when you watch a
movie and then you doing stand up and
stand up if something don't work right
we were like okay but that didn't work
let's say on screen head and tail miss
to say okay not gonna use that anymore
so for me as a comedian doing acting
it's it's it's a lot different because I
could always make it up and stand up I
could do the next joke I go okay I'm
gonna get him with this one back but it
was it was a great plan on doing more
actually I'm doing a movie coming up in
a couple weeks called spinning gold
where I play Giorgio Moroder who was the
father of disco and I have to do it we
talked about putting yourself in a
situation that you don't normally find
yourself in it's not disco know that I
could do the owner of one of the loony
Bin's in Oklahoma City who is a disco
dancing champion I remember he was used
to take me in a back room and show me
all his trophies his old outfits as
unitards or whatever bra no painters
yeah a lot of disco people were like
this [ __ ] onesies a lot of there's
nothing like a nice onesie that got that
guy yeah so I'm doing this with a German
accent so I'm working with like a
dialect coach to get like a German
accent yes and some point dog yeah
that's that's yeah okay
you know girl big must ask you I hope
they give me a mustache on set because
that that that mustache is beautiful
beautiful I sold half a handful of pubic
hair to a guy one time for a Halloween
mustache on a cruise ship true story we
needed hair Brian this guy was limited
dudes and I was [ __ ] carrying at the
time so I'll [ __ ] [ __ ] trimmed him
off a couple edges lady used honey know
if I can put it right up your stories I
don't know if you feel this way guys but
your stories are so off the beaten path
I often go is he making this [ __ ] up
yeah or did that really happen
yeah so yeah that happened oh yeah oh
yeah half a day trading pubic hair for
small money but hating pubic I mean I've
never even heard of that like when I
listen and I go that's made up right but
this guy's named Patricio from bra CEO
actually and I still follow me [ __ ]
he's a big Formula One racing fan but oh
yeah that dude
danced like a [ __ ] with somebody
else's [ __ ] pubic hair above his lip
okay he's a champion too this guy was
also a really cool guy okay but you're
on a cruise
yeah and how and this is a buddy of
yours Halloween yeah and he needs hair
for his lip yeah and you shave your
pubic hair off to give to him which he
puts on what honey huh yeah yeah I trim
a decent amount I have like a shave
anything how's that thought even coming
to your head going bro hold on let me
start shaving my puke oh look I was
thinking well I love my hair man you
know even though it's like it's getting
scarce on these days and I Manhattan a
little but yeah I love my hair and I
just knew it I don't want to give any of
that up at the time but I was like I got
this you know second batch of hair going
on bro
that you know it ain't no it's the A
Team B team down here I'll say your
[ __ ] quarter outs of it so you sold
it to him yep forty bucks on a crew
shock and a ticket for a wine cuz you
got tickets at night to see how much
wine and you could get like two wines or
something you know they had a
you know it's kind of like a Cuba or
something or you know like a system
where you get a voucher kind of thing I
didn't know there was a dollar amount on
pubes
there is now brother I think the change
in dude especially with all uh what was
I gonna ask you about man
oh hey or dude so I got I got PRP right
yeah yeah where they take part of your
blood out yeah and they've like well did
you get the transplant and then the PRP
or this is just okay I got the
transplant first okay so I got part of
the back taken out and put in the front
yeah cuz I love surgery you know and so
I got part of the back taken out put
into the front the very front and how
many how many hairs you revive hundred
five hundred
yeah that's not many that's that's
that's I mean I don't really see I mean
obviously you know you that's it well
that's a nice hairline man yeah I don't
know I don't think I mean I don't know
what the hell you were worried about I
had it done yeah and because I needed it
I mean you look like you got a mop make
it Italian here bro oh yeah well they
brought it I think I did
mm oh nice huh mm yeah I don't do the
PRP I don't do that
but you're seeing significant growth I
don't know if I am that's the problem
here's the trick who [ __ ] know what
I'm saying like how do you do look and
go wow this is getting thicker nothing I
mean well that was I think even with the
hairs it's like you know I don't know
they say they put them in and they they
put it all the way they cut it all the
way down to the root so they're not just
putting the full hair in they put just
the little seed right is that the
experience you had yeah well yeah well
they they take it out and they they take
from the root yes and then they plop it
into your your head yeah now do you know
that they could take because I asked
they go can you take other people's hair
and put it in your head and they said no
it won't take yeah but the second place
they take it from if you don't have any
of the back is underneath your your neck
right here don't these hairs out and
then really yeah well psycho we get that
bro what [ __ ] can
take out his neck hair and get put in
the top of his available bro it's
available pervert his running around his
neck hey some guy was [ __ ] pubic hair
on his lip and you're worried about neck
hair or making money on the high seas
Bukka okay
but dude that's crazy I would just feel
so [ __ ] gentle out there I could I'd
be way too gentle I feel like that
here's scary neck hair that's too much
man No so this PRP is what what is that
in they prick your head with blood yeah
yeah they said they take blood out of
your arm and I had a slow drip or
something I don't know if it was you
know apparently wasn't really that time
of the month in my arm you know because
dude it took them [ __ ] 20 minutes
they're both sitting there at one point
the guy's looking at [ __ ] on his phone
while he's like they're like well it's
good but it's just coming out real slow
which is way down half a quarter so you
know so they finally got it and they put
it in some machine that spins and I
guess gets like the best blood you have
yeah because people don't realize a lot
of their blood is just be you know be
c-team there's a lot of [ __ ]
miscreants running around in there you
know some cells are just said there's
waiting for a [ __ ] greyhound you know
this ain't a new one but you got a been
a team in there that's really kind of
doing most of the work so they get those
and then inject him in a certain parts
back in your head and you have the
process done what once a month or it's
supposed to be annually and I just had
it done
Oh cannulas it's been about a year since
I had the surgery so I think it's been
good though it's definitely been it was
interesting I thought and I was glad I
did it I felt me like made me feel kind
of proactive but I also give way
inferior about how I look you know and
so it's like you know sometimes I do
anyway comedies actually helped me with
that a little bit well your your your
appearance yeah cuz just like oh this is
how [ __ ] look at this point you know
it's like and also I think if you're too
handsome I don't know if you can be a
good comedian
you know it would just be it wouldn't be
I don't think a real handsome guy could
be a real community harder for them to
do it
I couldn't imagine if I was like a real
handsome guy like I'm 1/8 if I brush my
teeth right I'm a [ __ ] 8 you won't
see me in nine Vil you [ __ ] might see
me hanging around the seventh well I
mean eight is pretty high up on the
handsome meter if you if you write I
don't think I think everybody can be an
8 if they take care of themselves I
don't that is really 8 is a B right yeah
it's a B it's a B yeah so be it B it's
pretty damn handsome I am talking you
know CC - what's that's what we're
talking about
comedians right yeah I guess that's true
maybe my self you are no no man that's
crazy
maybe I try and hold the door in a sharp
elevator and [ __ ] come back here a
couple months of one-armed so yeah I
don't know so I had it done no I had it
done this guy in Beverly Hills this guy
dr. Kayne and he was awesome man I went
in there one or two times he's like you
don't need anything you know come back
in a year he wasn't trying to upsell me
on my own hair like a [ __ ] guy he got
pulling [ __ ] out of your neck I didn't
get it done and I'm just saying that's
an option if you want to go back and
start taking right out of your goatee
bro
that's wild man yeah it's funny I didn't
think I would ever be that type of
person who would do that but then
sometimes you just become people you
didn't think you would be I guess you
know and well you grow you learn
different things I guess you know so for
you so you got this podcast and you got
one with Brendan Schaub how do I like
tell me in the podcast world how does
that come about do you guys get together
and go there we should do another how
many how many of these things you got
going on what why don't we I'm out
what's this this is the weekend right
yeah there's another one that you have
hang in the sting okay but there's
another one that you just talked to the
camera by yourself
that's this past weekend but on Monday
episode and so
that is just comes out on Monday this
comes out on Thursday so how many of
these things you doing a week I'm doing
three up three a week three week all
right so it's pretty that's part of this
thing is that sometimes burnt me out a
little bit it's going on the road and
then like you know you get in Sunday and
then have to come here that night and do
an episode and then Tuesday do one with
Brendan Wednesday come in here and do a
guest episode so we're gonna scale back
a little bit I think not through it
we've got Amanda Knox coming in next
week oh yeah this is your this is foxy
Knoxy dude it's so funny I told you that
the other night you're like what are you
gonna ask about and as the first time it
hit me like I don't know well do you
like come into these things with like
prepared like or is it just kind of like
we're just gonna wing it or I mean like
on the way over are you going are you in
your head going with Amanda Knox okay
I'm gonna ask her this this or do you
just take your jacket off put your hat
on and go okay love we're talking yeah
yeah I think that's it I'm gonna ask her
mmm let me see I was gonna ask her like
about the media and stuff and how much
she thinks like it controls everything
does she think that the truth even
matters a lot of times and then alright
so there's some thought that's caught
into this yes there's a little bit of
thought into it and then she has a
husband now and then I was gonna yeah
ask her what she looks for in a man
and if she thinks like you know how many
guys tried to hook up with her just
because maybe she killed somebody or
allegedly you know and then what else
that's probably about it sorry to
interrupt the episode here with the host
of the VMAs is so crazy bruh can't even
believe that but I got to let you know
that if you don't have a skill then what
are you doing think about somebody that
doesn't have a skill hitch-hiker you
know someone that's missing that's it
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
25000 classes and design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fuel your creates create curiosity
creativity and career if you're if
you're not doing something you want to
be doing something the only way to get
there is to take action Skillshare is an
easy way to do it don't go back to
college
by a lunch pail and do all at at your
nuts take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing or even illustration whether
you're looking to discover a new passion
start a side hustle or gain professional
skills these are real skills that you
can use in your life think about your
life could have skills in it join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare dot-com slash
Theo von to start your two months now
that Skillshare dot-com slash Theo von
oh I use this do you do you use this
this is honey have you ever bought
something online only to find out later
that you missed a discount I have you
get you something get that cheap collar
jacket that long arm batty and later on
you find out all they got a different
one for nineteen dollars less better
sheep don't overspend anymore thanks to
honey honey is a free browser add-on
that finds the best deals online I use
it in my laptop it's easy got it one
time put it on if I'm buying something
I'll click on honey first and it lets me
know if there's a better place
honey finds discounts and coupons across
37,000 sites
Amazon Sephora Best Buy Nordstrom and
more ijust shop like normal honey
handles the rest if you thinking you're
gonna have to go to a million sites and
look how much is this guitar you know
how much is this some you know this
hermit crab sanctuary whatever dude
honey does all the hard work and how do
you feel when honey saves you money you
feel tight you feel great
look there's no real reason not to use
honey it's free to use and easy to
install on your computer in just two
clicks so shop with confidence like
I do I'm confident when I'm shopping get
honey for free at join honey dot-com /
Theo that's Jo I in a Chow in a why.com
/ th EO it's very simple and it's very
effective don't get to the checkout
right before you click buy wonder should
I go see where Consumer Reports tells me
to go or wear this or wear that honey
does all the work go to join honey calm
/ Theo the smart shopping assistant that
saves you time and money when you're
shopping online and now back to this
movie star comedian Wow well we got some
user questions that come in we'll get to
one of those right now what I'm
Sebastian this is Steven from
Connecticut my question is so I know
Sebastian's been on comedians in cars
getting coffee two times now and it's
written in some various vehicles those
scooters were definitely interesting
my question is Sebastian if Theo was to
ride in a car with Jerry Seinfeld what
car should Jerry pick him up in gang
gang gang well for you I'm seeing like a
older I'm seeing a Monte Carlo oh good I
was a holder man okay what is it Marty
caller you pulled it up Nick like maybe
nine and 1981 Monte Carlo with t-tops
yeah I like to do with red interior yeah
the I don't know if it's a t yeah that's
it like that one that black one
yeah something that like like that is
that you yeah man that's beautiful bro a
little bit of coke on the seat he's not
mine I'm just listening to music that
ain't mine sir coke under C no I don't
think comedians and cars has the Coca
[Laughter]
you don't need the coffee then yeah
that's a beautiful vehicle right there I
would do also maybe like a Ford f-150
like a 1980 you like a truck you know
what I miss I like that bench seat I
think yeah it's a lot that's like a
that's you know something simple like
that it's just simple it's like a farm
vehicle yeah like a dog in the back
maybe Oh something you could put a you
know something you could eat as soon as
you get home in the back but after you
clean it mm-hmm it's like a hunting
truck yeah yeah I guess that is a little
bit of a hunter vehicle oh here's
somebody right here yo yo mr. Maniscalco
Johnny here in North Carolina just a
question for you guys since you come
from two totally different types of
backgrounds but ten-year-old Theo and
ten-year-old Sebastian Maniscalco you
you come in from outside playing with
your friends sit down on a couch with
your dirty clothes I put your feet up on
the coffee table
what do you follow those responses Gang
Gang I love you love you too buddy
I know sweat and also first of all guys
drenched I hope he's doing okay yeah I
don't know what he lived through the end
of this it look like getting it abruptly
yeah Thank You Johnny and hope you're
doing well
um so first of all I come from playing
outside ain't sitting on no furniture
it's a shower right right away Wow
what's in my house ten years old fake it
a shout straight to the show and you put
your feet up on the furniture yeah yeah
yeah that guy's got a unique areas
living yeah my dad I don't know my dad
was asleep my dad was 80 years old when
I was ten years old so yeah you had an
older father right last time I think we
are yeah you said you had an older dead
my dad used to borrow money from me to
[ __ ] him for gas you know cuz you never
work they don't hiring a lot of 80 year
olds
you know in a lot of places yeah so he's
- um yeah he used to bar gas money from
me and like I had a [ __ ] job dude so
that's crazy only where he thought I was
getting
from but no and I was just kind of
stealing somewhere for my mom oh damn
we had some dirty back channels in the
house but what my dad my dad wouldn't
notice about that kind of stuff that
kind of stuff was just too menial I
think too little but what else we got
third video centrality of me oh damn I'm
sorry I bought us a fish so you don't
have Nikita yeah he wants you to speak
on having a kid I just had to play that
video so he doesn't think we're racist
those the third one so now appreciate it
and thanks brother we're not raised
sister I'm not trying to be you know I
have some flare-ups in traffic but
overall I'm good you know I'm doing my
best man I'm out here on the front lines
of not trying to be brother thank you
for for sending in the video speak on
having a kid man yeah has it changed
your perception or anything a little bit
of like the world do you look at the
world any different well yeah look at
everyday life different I mean before
you know you had a kid it's just about
you and your wife and now everything is
like I told my daughter was was sick
last night so it's just the world stops
we were supposed to go see the Los
Angeles football club play last night at
the at the exposition park those plans
are gone you know it's just it's all
about that kid God that team sounds like
I'm miserable I know you heard that [ __ ]
I'm in some [ __ ] shady League I got a
[ __ ] I got two grand going on [ __ ]
Winchester this afternoon outside of
South Wales so I'm gonna let anything
never heard of that group yeah okay it's
right in our backyard
okay I'm supposed to be an amazing
experience it's there in the MLS soccer
soccer soccer yeah okay I was thinking
of All American football no no take your
kid to the [ __ ] Rams game cheapskate
it's affordable fun for the whole family
uh
so I heard it's supposed to be almost
like a European type of atmosphere oh
nice yeah you know sometime yeah yeah
yeah
the INGOs so we're supposed to go there
last night so long story short in
regards to the kid you know everything
revolves around the kid it's all about
the kiddy golf for a walk you know in
the neighborhood and you know you're
scanning what's going on around you
before you I take a walk by yourself you
could give a [ __ ] if you got stabbed but
right now it's like what's going on over
here let's you know it's it's dog over
here yes does that that's that's a good
point these dogs you know and then my
kid goes up to the dog and then and I
love these owners where you look I scan
the owner uh-huh right and I'm like does
this guy if things break out could he
even contain the damn thing so I'm doing
all that 50 yards in advance so like god
this guy's all right or if it's somebody
who's like some weak kid never goes out
once a year to walk like 30 dogs to make
all of his money to go back and listen
dungeon and just get all K hold out and
just play games until he needs it you
know till he needs to buy a pack of
ramen again the next winter you know and
he's got like 40 dogs on a leash he's
out there I did a ride and somewhere in
Brentwood like this rockin kid can't
handle himself yes I guess you got a
lookout because the kid doesn't look at
the kid isn't thinking about those
things
she almost have to take part of the
kid's brain you almost have to be part
of their brain I guess huh yeah well
yeah you you are you know guiding this
child and then some good metaphor
through life you know and not only when
you're walking around the block but you
know as they grow older you know and
giving them advice trying to lead them
down the right path we're very big on
manners and please and thank you because
I see a lot of brats out there you know
I go to a lot of these you know I go to
the park and I see I attempt my way I
mean look at this kids yeah you know I
see like the kid that's not in misbehave
it's always got some weird booger
hanging out of his nose and whatnot and
yeah so you know I take yeah especially
how I grew up
I grew up with like a lot of like
structure you know and I'm trying to
instill that in our kids so that's
that's my rap on the kids
is it hard to you start to worry about
like being a parent and being able to be
around for your kids enough with with
to warn and stuff like that yeah so my
daughter's been to 23 cities already and
our son it's gonna be a little bit
harder to travel with two kids but
they're coming to the VMAs they'll come
to like really large event type shows
where you know maybe Chicago where I'm
from they'll go back there but yeah I I
cut out the whole summer
to be at home nice and and and hang with
the family and again we were talking
about just having some balance you know
and I can't always be on the road at
least for me with a family I just I need
to this to cut out some some segments in
the schedule to hang with my my daughter
my son my wife so I make that a priority
yeah it looks like you get that fun man
i watch a lot of your Instagram stories
and it's like all you guys having a
blast on arrow it's all that's all we do
at the house it's all about fun yeah we
there's serious moments don't get me
wrong but my wife and I were constantly
ripping each other to shreds especially
her on me you know that there's no room
that's how I grew up too I mean I got
friends like speaking of comedians in
cars my buddy called me said Bryce are
you convenience okay you look cold man
the hell you hungover you know like
there's no there's no filter you know
it's just that we just constantly make
fun of one another and that's like yeah
I'm hungover from 40 years of our life
that's great
so yeah keeps me grounded
what's a DM that you've got from like
somebody who is like a Fanny or like
somebody you really admire like
something nice like that did anything
ever happen like that like Dennis Rodman
sent me a peace sign the other day for
everything and then never wrote me back
right this is about two weeks ago so did
you write him back from the peace sign
yeah I wrote oh thanks man and then and
then I asked him something like what's
going on you know do you live in LA or
something and I didn't get anything bad
but it was just kind of interesting yeah
it's always it's always the first DM I
really got through it was actually
through Twitter was about six or seven
years ago and it was from JJ Watt Wow he
was a rookie in the league and he had
reached out to me via Twitter and said
that he had been a fan since high school
and then and I started to think wow I'm
really getting old because this guy was
in high school when he picked up what I
was doing right and then we've been you
know we became fast friends we've been
friends forever since so that that was
pretty cool and the rock had posted a
clip of he was watching my comedy and he
posted up on and that that had to be
eating moment thanked on well I mean out
of all the stuff I've done that one got
like people coming out of the woodwork
for 20 the rock put your stuff on his
Instagram who's bigger than any like
network and everything bigger than all
the specials everything but one share of
the rock yeah Wow Sheridan uh and I was
getting like did you see what the rock
did so yeah it's it's cool you know to
to because you don't even know like when
you're doing this stuff you don't know
who you're hitting who's getting to this
right now
whose senior comedy and with the
internet it gives you an idea of you
know how how far your tentacles are
reaching people and it's cool to see
like oh he's a fan or she's a fan I
wouldn't think they would like maybe
like what I do or what have you but it's
it's flattering yeah yeah it's
interesting how how much access everyone
kind of has to everybody really yeah I
mean if the internet was around when I
was a kid you know I'd be like popping
DMS two prints going bro love what
you're doing you know like let's dance
yes dance got my biz girl outfit what do
you think now as you start to like you
act in films up did you ever think that
you would do that though I mean I just
feel like it would have to be no do you
ever think that I mean I think a lot of
comedians think a sitcom or something
sometimes it's kind of a natural train
of thought especially like you know
coming up in the air and time that
you've come up and through comedy but
you ever do you ever think movies that I
mean you really I wanted to do movies
but I wanted to do a little bit more
serious roles than comedic goofy stuff
I'm not a goofy guy not so I'm actually
a serious guy serious the serious roles
kind of play to my personality kind of
off stage of just kind of being a little
bit more straight than then like hey you
know it's just it's not it's not what I
do so I like the
fact that this serious dramatic roles
give me a nice little departure from
what I do to you know day in day out on
stage and I think it's a nice little
contrast for me so yeah I've always had
movies in the back of my mind not not to
be like a movie star right but to do
like projects here and there a little
pop into a movie pop out you know I
don't want to be the guy that's like you
know maybe carrying the movie and
something a lot of responsibility yeah I
mean especially if you don't you know do
it on a regular basis but yeah I like
what I'm doing with these movies and I'm
fortunate enough to make a living doing
stand-up where I could do the acting and
it doesn't have to feed my family and I
Sam so I don't have to take a role just
to take it because movies don't pay
anything yeah there's not I mean for me
it's more of a exposure and being in a
broader broader audience similar to you
know like the podcasts you know like you
go on a podcast and hopefully you know
coming on your podcast you know we'll
send people to see the film yeah and you
know I'm reaching people that maybe
don't know who I am or or again and see
what this guy's podcast is all about and
and whatnot so I like kind of and also I
like you and and and you're a cool cat
and it's like I don't go on everybody's
podcast but you know ya know appreciated
man I mean I've always looked up to you
once ever since I got turned on to him
and I just yeah you kind of reminded me
always that like like an entertainer can
kind of still there is still something
to that like I always like it started to
feel like comedy was just about like
joke writers and stuff and if maybe that
was my own you know fears or something
but like oh man he's just it's just
people that are writers that they're
putting on stage and and but then seeing
you was like oh man you can still be
like an entertainer you know you can
still be you can still have dreams
somewhere your head if you're you know
like I remember even asking you for
advice one time you said just go watch
Michael Jackson Munich you know after
you [ __ ] told me and the Improv with
my wife I think you've met my wife for
the first time we yeah you know at the
improv this is about maybe six seven
years ago but you were back then in
maybe I'm wrong by saying this but back
then you you weren't a very happy man
you were you were
not as happy as you are right now yeah
and you were you know you were I don't
know you were kind of struggling and not
not let your career but just kind of I
could just feel like when we were
talking you were and that maybe not not
so good of a place I remember my wife
and I talking as we left it had such a
nice guy but he feels like he's a little
down and whatnot so is that is that
correct and saying yeah yeah I think
that's pretty true yeah I think I
started to get a little bit of a wall
like I wasn't gonna have you know I just
didn't know if I was doing the right
thing the opportunities you know didn't
seem like they were presenting any of
themselves mm-hmm but yeah I mean that's
a good a good example of someone that
might not think it's going to happen and
maybe running into these roadblocks and
all of a sudden boom look at this we're
an Borden podcast ville yeah you know I
mean it's like it's just it happens you
know and you gotta you gotta stick with
it and next thing you know you got your
own graffiti it's gotta happen do we
have any other questions from the crew
here were any of those guys an Irishman
like since they're all Italian guys were
they fans of your comedy and watched it
and yeah I didn't know if they knew what
I even did or if they knew I was a
stand-up comedian I didn't know any of
that so going into this the first day
when DeNiro came out he came up to me
and he said he don't good things
oh my god does he did someone tell him
to say that
or does he know what a trade so yeah I
didn't know I didn't know what the hell
they knew and I still don't I mean I the
Nero had came to my show at Radio City
after Irishman which we talked backstage
more than we ever talked on set on so I
didn't talk to him at all
really so you just go do your stuff and
then kind of go back to your corner yeah
well they they went to their corner and
I went to my corner yeah
and you know they were talking amongst
themselves like it would be like cutting
in De Niro and Pesci and Scorsese would
kind of talk amongst themselves and then
I'd be like I wasn't gonna go in the
huddle though yeah yeah I think so too
you know like what am I gonna do on the
sidelines like I'm gonna have another
mini snicker predict my future decide if
I'm good enough to hang out here for
another minute yeah wow that's a man
that would be very intimidating man well
they all know each other they work
together yeah all right they got their
own thing going so I you know I was like
then the new guy there in that
particular scene and you know I'm
looking at it like if I'm not invited in
the huddle right you know ain't gonna go
over there yeah no of course but yeah I
didn't I didn't talk to really anyone on
set because I didn't know if it's
another thing that yell cut I don't know
if this guy's still in character or I
don't know what he's doing
yeah they yell cut and I'm thinking okay
yeah you know I'm me yeah I'm not like
doing some like method where I'm like
you know hold on listen you know they
can't talk to me because I'm still too
crazy Joe gallo
yeah cut then like you said I'm you know
getting a little cube cheese cheddar so
I don't wanna like interrupt anybody's
process yeah but well you may talk good
of actors they were I was um I I don't
really remember the only thing I do
remember is me thinking while I was
acting that I couldn't believe I was
doing this with these guys yeah so I
mean I don't even know if that's being
in the moment and acting when you're
thinking you know yeah definitely not
but I mean yeah you relate to it look
you're in a lifeguard chair up above
yourself kind of a little bit yeah dude
what are you [ __ ] doing down there
huh ro that's the adult pool the [ __ ]
a flip resolve buddy but yeah I I could
imagine that your mouth moving in a
little bit of your head also talking
like
okay here we go yeah a lot a lot of like
inner dialogue yeah while I'm doing
dialogue yeah which I think with
comedians do though I mean don't you
ever go on stage and talk to yourself in
your head while you're speaking to the
audience sometimes yeah yeah so this was
just that I was actually taking in the
the moment and I couldn't believe what
was happening but then I'm also acting
at the same time which is probably not
the best thing to do but I'm sorry I had
to these are like the guys I grew up
watching yeah man it's kind of crazy
because especially like being you know
being an Italian guy you grew up I mean
those are those are the guys mm-hmm you
know that are still alive those really
guys yeah and some best alone the
brother Sylvester who's the brother
Frank Frank Stallone did I see Frank Jim
always trying to pump a lot of young
bucket so you know all the time but we
can always take that out if we need to
but Harmon
that's an edit but I know a lot of you
have been hit on though Frank Stallone
he's almost like Pauly Shore at CBS
Pauly you try to bang every girl that
was looking for a birthday card at CBS
well I know nine girls that have been I
was just looking for a birthday card and
probably should be so many times right
it's crazy it's a really good grand cuz
you know there's a woman there's like
sentimental she cares about her she's
caring you know this you know you're not
you know you're meeting somebody that's
not somebody that's picking out a
[ __ ] you know 24 pack of [ __ ] hot
nuts over about a sprite you know that
girl who is that
wow man so did does it feel a little bit
like like when you're working with your
idols is it is it almost then hard to
find like what's next to keep you
excited or is a German dialect really
true it's not very no honestly you're
right
it's it's insane bro it's something that
you after that experience and that
experience probably should have came at
the end of a career right but it came at
the kind of like the beginning
it sounds like where do you go
thereafter you're coming off such a big
high but yeah I mean I just want to do
stuff that I'm really really passionate
about and with people who are really
talented and and know what they're doing
Wow so in the the you're gonna be
dancing in this and the new film you're
gonna know it's about it's about disco
in the 70s and I'm like the one of the
fathers of disco just because of the way
this Giorgio Moroder did a lot of sounds
and music behind the vocalist he was you
know responsible responsible for Donna
Summer in short but yeah there's no
dancing oh yeah no just that there's a
couple of scenes I'm in but there's
there's no there's no although if it
requires dancing I am more than happy
yeah you see doing that no I gotta tell
ya I grew up dancing oh yeah we went to
dance clubs that's all we did Miguel
were like sock hops YMCA would you guys
go - no we went - they used to call them
dance parties and Osaka this wasn't this
was at a this is not a Sun on a Sunday
night at a bar called todos oh yeah
which turned into a teen dance club on
Sunday night right so we go and me and
my buddy Francesco had these shirts made
up and I'm the back and I say they talk
about weird your audience will love this
we had on the back of the shirt
Italian boys and we used to be in him
used to do the same move with the shirt
size you guys are synchronized as
science synchronized Italian dancers
like we would practice all week because
we thought we were gonna pick up girls
because of the way we danced right but
this is the eighties so many hand
movements our buddy died out there was a
lot of up here you know
the hands are always up by the head for
some reason lettle look offs so uh
that's the whole like my my from 16
years old to about 22 I had a fake ID at
16 and my figure he was unbelievable and
whose was it was it actually you or
somebody else's me Wow
it was me and it was my dad actually
helped me get it and I used to buy
alcohol for guys were older than than me
we were going to the club's I didn't
really hang out in high school I didn't
go to the basketball games football
games what we were doing is we were
going to dance parties and then when we
got the ID we were going to bar so I was
17 I was hanging out at you know over 21
nightclubs yeah and dancing I didn't
wear the Italian boy shirt did it yeah
that was a lot it was a limited yeah I
was limited you know a summer so great
so yeah that's what we were that's
that's kind of how I grew up that that
whole you know taking care of the car
you know I used to drive a 1982 Seville
with white walls spoked rims beautiful
slanted back trunk
oh yeah that's sexy bra with that out
without line of the spare tire yeah Oh
God
but a spoke rim on the back oh yeah man
is class is different now isn't it just
it's different this thing's feeling a
little less classy yeah I think that's a
lot less classy I just there's like a
decorum back then at least where I grew
up that you kind of had respect for your
elders you you know you just if you did
something you didn't want to embarrass
your family yeah you know like now
people sue their families they can hire
a lawyer to sue and all you
[ __ ] for raising me it's gotten
crazy it's crazy there's no family
respect anymore it's different well the
family dynamic is not there anymore you
don't have you don't have the family
anymore everybody's too wrapped up in a
video game or and I don't mean to sound
like some old man but the way we grew up
and I think the way our family was
structured was you know you said the
kitchen table and you were talking to
your parents there was no like
your attention span wasn't here or there
it was like we're eating and you know
we'd sit at the table for two hours just
talking with my parents my parents were
the type of parents where everybody
wanted to hang out at our house my
parents were like like the fun you know
they loved my friends and talking to
them and we like the end of the movie
and the guy the book great green book
yeah yeah similar to that vibe where
everybody's around and eating eating
kind of like food brought everybody
together but anyway you just don't see
that now it's just it's it's it still
exists and I think people are longing
for that but now it's like you know you
go out to a restaurant you see a family
everybody's on the under the device and
we've dialed out yeah yeah devices are
part of our lifestyle don't get me wrong
it's not like you have to totally put it
put it away but even with our kids we're
teaching them you know you get it for a
small amount of time and then after that
you know let's let's get back to the
burrata getting over here there's no app
better than burrata all right I got a
[ __ ] hot batch of burrata
I fell off a boat in Providence I want
you to try good on you guys in yeah but
you got Jionni we just have one patreon
question for Sebastian all right and it
is from faber check and if you were
invited to a potluck dinner
what homemade dish would you bring and
who would you bring not your wife
someone else potluck dinner what would I
bring there is a Sicilian dish called
pasta taeyeon which is which is pasta
layered with strip steak pine nuts
some Reds a red sauce it's layered I
think it takes a long time to you don't
hear about that a lot
no it's very very specific to actually
it's not even Sicilian this it's it's a
it's a town in Sicily called Chef aloo
or my father's from it's very specific
to that town and who would I bring my
father if it wasn't my wife I'd bring my
father my father's a character he is
he's a hairstylist and he has he's where
I pretty much get a lot of the he thinks
he's a comedian behind the tree
everybody everybody loves my dad at the
salon you must be so proud of you then
huh my dad is very proud of 74 he's
still cutting hair so young well I mean
74 to be cutting hair I mean it's like
people went it's a young business it's
not like people are walking in the salon
going
I'll have the guy with the ARP card cut
my hair you know he's one of the
military well he's not a barber he's a
stylist so he does women's hair he does
he does colors he does all that stuff
but he's had clients for for 40 years
and their pasts in a way that time and
in the will they are requesting my
father to do the last Shabazz dead hair
so my father's going to funeral parlors
and he loves it because they don't say
nothing they don't you know they don't
ask you know he just does what he has to
do I just leaned over and I did the hair
who would have [ __ ] that suits
horrible but hey look a boy so yeah it's
yeah he's very proud my foot my whole
family's very proud yeah is it hard to
embrace sometimes like how ah
is it hard like like I get worried
sometimes as my career gets bigger that
like you know I don't want my family to
ever think that I'm different or
anything does that do you ever worry
about that kind of stuff no I think I
mean listen I'm 46 years old I've been
at this for 21 years I've been the same
guy when I moved out here in 1998 that I
am now regardless of success or what has
happened to me over the last three or
four years very very grounded coming in
to Los Angeles with family and friends
and no I mean my family is you know
they're they treat me as if you know I
was 21 24 years old when I first came
out here they've just there's no
difference yeah it's pretty much the
same yeah I think it was we I think I
asked you that last time too and it's
kind of a similar answer but that's
awesome man it's cool to hear it's
inspiring and it's insightful
wow man living your dreams dude living
the dream and dreams out you didn't even
have do
Mays VMAs and and yeah when I first came
out here it was it was stand-up comedy
that's all I wanted to do just stand-up
comedy I didn't I didn't like I said put
on any goal
there's no goals it was just to do
stand-up comedy and then whatever
happened after that it was like gravy to
me so for me to be in the position I'm
into to do all these really great things
I'm very I never take it for granted I'm
very fortunate and I'm always wondering
you know like for me the fear is to try
to stay consistent and and not you know
like whatever comes up is gonna come
down eventually right but you kind of
want to get to a certain place and just
and really maintain you know like that's
why when you go to my show I'm always
trying to rewrite new material just to
bring the people back or you know go on
shows like this and give more of a
little bit of my personality and
personal side of me so people get to
know the ins and outs of who I am so
yeah and bringing people along on your
journey you know it's pretty cool I
think um yeah a lot of people just they
want to kind of know what it's like just
from like a regular perspective you know
not from like some of that's very canned
you know they want to fresh out the
garden you know fresh off the gum yeah
you had this bit the other day come on
swimming which is great I'm not going to
talk about it because you know I know
that you know people be coming out to
see it but over at UCLA that bit you
were doing yeah so I'm swimming I
started swimming forty-six years old and
I never learned to swim before and I'm
taking swimming lessons at UCLA with a
an ex Olympian he's German actually
learn the accent at the same time
one last thing so you were saying let me
get this let me get this thought right
so did you start to worry at some point
that if you got married or settled down
or something that it was going to damage
like your thinking process or your
performance process or anything like
that when it came to stand up early on I
thought that way I thought hey I don't
want anything kind of impeding my
process here of like touring I don't
want a girlfriend telling me hey you
can't go on the road because we haven't
spent time together so early on I
thought let me just get to where I need
to
get to and then you know then maybe I'll
find someone settle down have a family I
don't think I could have done what I'm
doing now with kids and a wife ten years
ago just because of the amount of time
and energy it takes to put in III told
my agent I said book me wherever you can
I don't care if it's Monday through
Sunday in Las Vegas 14 shows I'll do
whatever it takes to establish an
audience and what not so when you got
kids in a family at home that's very
difficult I really don't know how guys
do it it's it's it's it's amazing when I
hear like three kids and he's you know
trying to get to the top but for me the
personality I have am I kind of all or
nothing so you know I just think it
happened organically for me when I met
my wife it just it kind of all fit this
right place right time this is let's
like let's go on this journey together
we'll start having kids when you know we
we could afford it and then available
for the kids
so yeah in early on I definitely did not
want to have a family and or a a steady
that would kind of keep me from where I
wanted to go yeah which is kind of
selfish but you have to be though a
little yeah and you have to have a
little bit of selfishness to to put the
time and energy it takes to get to where
you need to go there's a lot of
sacrifice I think people don't really
realize you know like even over the
years like I've had missed a lot of
people's weddings like or events back at
home I lost friends because I said I
would be at the wedding and I couldn't
make it you know because I just got a
new agent and they just got me a weekend
and I didn't want to lose him you know
just uh here's a lot of weird sacrifice
of people nurse saying sometimes pets
come home you [ __ ] pass the dead you
know yeah I never had that happen but he
series really
I never there's a whole group of us that
if EV [ __ ] lost animals because oh my
god no for me it was no pets no
girlfriend no kids and I and I and I
totally relate to you when you said
missing weddings I missed a really good
friend of Mines wedding back in Chicago
because I just didn't have the money to
go huh and I had to work I was working
as a waiter you know and and you know
unfortunately I probably made the wrong
decision at the time I probably should
have found a way to go but yeah there
you're right there's a lot of sacrifice
you got to make if you want to if you
want to succeed hopefully you don't lose
friends doing it but um it's the risk
you gotta take man best of luck man
thanks so much for coming on thank you
for and we'll put all of your stuff at
the beginning and tell people about the
famine yeah man that was so cool seeing
you in the green book man oh thanks man
it was so nice to see me up on the big
screen I know pretty cool
did you start to feel yourself like
towards it like you're like oh wow I
kind of got the hang of this a little
bit yeah like I mean I think your
assessment on the acting from from front
to back was it was dead-on accurate that
first scene was a like I said the first
scene iv Center I've ever done and then
as I shot that out of the cannon and got
to know the director more Peter Farrelly
was the director and you know here's
another guy loved his comedy movie so is
another intimidating working with him
and and I was just hoping to get it
right and then you know the scenes after
that I felt a lot more at home it's just
like anything else you go to first day
of school you don't know what to expect
you're probably not yourself and then
after you make a friend or two you start
to kind of let down your guard hopefully
when I'm moving forward I could act when
I when I when it's the first day of
shooting I could act like it's the
second week of school right you know I'm
saying yeah a little more dialed in yeah
you know maybe got a gun on your waist
maybe a nice trip to my I don't know
Sebastian Maniscalco thank you so much
man best of all best of luck we look
before to seeing you everywhere thank
you
[Music]
like these leaves I must be I'll share
this thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]
moving way too fast on the runaway train
with a heavy levels of in these wheels
that are been robbed no they want this
damn
[Music]
I can't wait
if you call my name
[Music]
[Applause]